spider-man this is mr. Beck here
Mysterio clam stock chose we need an
Avenger awesome
mr. stark trusted me I'm not gonna let
him down let's go save the world
spider-man
I've got this I have a planet first for
this class track I want to do something
that's not on the itinerary
second I'm gonna tell him J how I feel
all right
I'm spider-man no of course I was three
I kind of want to do something fun
don't do any of that why because we're
gonna be bachelors in Europe Europeans
love Americans really spider-man far
from home starts July 2nd in IMAX hey
everybody its charlie we got some brand
new spider-man far from home footage to
breakdown and a lot of you asking about
venom crossing over so I wanted to do a
video for that because there's been a
lot of rumors and there's a lot of stuff
that the people that made venom Tom
Hardy and Tom Holland and the Marvel
people behind spider-man that have said
about it we're doing that new spider-man
far from home IMAX take a giveaway - all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a spider-man
comment on the video uh name a new
winner at the end of this we start with
new footage of extra abilities we didn't
know about that the new spider-man suit
has the special Steve Ditko so that he
fabricates on the back of Iron Man's jet
here it's all happening before that big
molten man boss fight where he goes
super-sized over the Tower Bridge of
London so you see him climb to the
outside of the jet but then when he lets
go instead of just gliding down you see
a special new parachute shoot out of the
back out of his symbol he had a
parachute in the original Iron Man stark
tech suit but it looked a little bit
different and if you remember during
spider-man homecoming he actually got
tangled in it so it didn't quite work
the way that it was supposed to work so
it sounds like this new version is a
slightly fixed version so that he won't
get tangled in it when he jumps down
into this Maelstrom but it shoots out of
his back the same way that the last
symbol did this time it's white though I
think he just pops a little bit more
on-screen and you also noticed the white
outline remember the black outline from
the stark tech suit there's a white
outline on his suit here that we don't
see when he's standing stationary on the
ground so maybe this just lights up or
has something to do with the operation
of this suit but this might be behind
all those spider UK rumors that people
have been talking about the earth that
Mysterio claims to come from in the
multiverse is spider UK's Earth and then
separately there was some merchandise
that looked a little bit like a version
of spider UK's suit so we just created a
lot of confusion this might be what's
behind all those rumors so it might just
be part of the functionality of the
Steve Ditko stark tech suit so because
the parachute is white it might just
glow white in that outline of his suit
when it's deployed we'll get into
multiverse stuff when I talk about venom
in a second but then there's just more
footage
his friends geeking out on Mysterio
thinking he's super badass then there's
more footage of him at school before the
trip giving that leads his plan for what
he's gonna try and do with Michelle you
also see all these Ironman drawings on
the board behind him here too so it
sounds like the entire city is gonna be
a memorial to Ironman probably all over
the world to then net leads giving
spider-man probably the worst possible
advice that you could give someone as
you would expect his high school friend
to give him no no no I got all the
answers you need to be a super smooth
the funny thing about Ned Leeds giving
him all that misinformation about how
much tail they're gonna get with all
these European women is is that he
himself starts going out with Betty
Brant it's unclear when that happens
because in all the other trailer footage
of them going around Europe with the
tour group you see the two of them
together being a super annoying couple
so it's not really clear when this
relationship begins I believe I'm gonna
get a chance to see the movie early so
if I do I'll post a non-spoilery review
but for some reason my twitter account
isn't working so if you follow me on
Facebook or Instagram
I'll post updates there until I get my
Twitter account fixed so Kenny do the
important stuff venom crossover
everybody wants to see venom and
spider-man crossover in a movie there's
obviously a lot of hurdles that they
have to jump over before they can do
something like that
but you've probably been reading a bunch
of rumors because Tom Holland still has
a movie on his contract with Sony after
spider-man far from home and they
haven't announced the next Avengers
movie because obviously spider-man is
still in the MCU until you're told
otherwise but all they've said about
venom versus carnage is that that's
going to be the venom sequel hey they're
still in the middle of working on that
script they won't start shooting that
movie for a while but they're still
making that next venom sequel with
carnage but like I said it's all about
multiverse there's really five things
that need to happen to cross venom over
with spider-man including both practical
stuff behind the scenes as well as story
stuff within the universes within the
context of what the characters are doing
in their next movies so number 5 they
had to get both the characters their
origin story which they did was
spider-man homecoming Captain America
Civil War in the first venom movie you
have to establish the venom character
before you can cross him over with
spider-man and because Kevin Feige
didn't really express an interest in
using the venom character right away and
Sony felt like there was some
Sophos to be had with him they wanted to
do a solo movie so soon he just kind of
did its own thing with the first venom
movie number four venom had to do well
enough at the box office
Tom Hardy had to prove himself as the
character even though he's fantastic and
I didn't really doubt him as a performer
but you just don't know what it's gonna
look like till you actually see it so
had the character been a failure there
probably would have been no chance for
future crossover with spider-man but in
success all things are possible number
three they had to establish the concept
of the multiverse in at least one of the
movies because venom was made with the
intent that it be its own thing not part
of the MCU naturally by design in the
way they say like Black Panther doesn't
have any spider-man in it but because
they're both in the MCU and they both
came from Captain America Civil War you
know that they're part of the same story
universe it was a really funny Tom Hardy
quote not my daddy's tractor where he
talks about crossing over with
spider-man and how they designed the
venom movie to be its own thing do you
feel like this will be woven into that
this like Legion of super-heroes well I
mean do you even want to be already a
complete standalone piece and when I
read it I'm quite mercenary and quite
selfish in that aspect I'm very very
happy to have a standalone character
within the Marvel context in one world
but all to myself so I'm kind of greedy
in aspect but at the end of the day
that's that's that's kind of above my
paygrade and also it's not my daddy's
tractor so I don't know where it fits it
in the grand scheme of things but I
would never rule anything out there are
multiple realities Peter this is earth
dimension six one six nine from Earth
eight three three we share identical
physical constants level four symmetry
I'm sorry you're saying there's a
multiverse so this is why multiverse is
the key for doing crazier crossovers
with new characters from other Studios
because a weird rights situations with
the spider-man characters so Sony still
technically controls all the spider-man
900 plus characters they really are nine
hundred plus characters out of the
spider-man comics that Sony has access
to but you have to do the legwork of
establishing that concept which they
just did during Avengers and Game
Avengers infinity war and now spider-man
far from home - there has to be a clear
desire to cross them over from everyone
involved
Tom Holland Tom Hardy the producers
Kevin Feige the Sony people at both
studios Tom
Tom Hardy have both said a lot about
crossing the characters over Tom Holland
is a big fan of the venom character Tom
Hardy really wants to work with Tom
Holland even the director of venom said
that he tried to lay the groundwork for
a future crossover with the spider-man
character in the first venom movie this
is his quote he says I think we lay the
groundwork in this film for a pretty fun
matchup in the future so I think that
it'll be a really exciting story to
explore but I'd be lying if I didn't say
I'd love to see him face off against
spider-man at some point it feels like
that's inevitable and I know that Tom
Hollands excited about it and I know
that Tom Hardy's excited about it so
it's just a question of when and where I
guess that seems like the natural
evolution so it does seem like Sony is
trying to get Tom Holland into its venom
verse movies as quickly as possible the
way the venom director talked about the
crossover though made it sound more like
the intent is to put Tom Holland inside
the venom verse movies as opposed to
putting venom inside an MCU movie
remember when venom was supposed to be
rated R they said it was going to be
super hardcore everybody got really
pumped up by that it wound up being
pg-13 part of the reason for that is to
make it easier to bring spider-man a
very pg-13 character into a future
sequel it'd be really weird if you did
an r-rated venom movie then suddenly the
sequel was pg-13 number one though there
has to be clear reason to cross
spider-man inventive over on a story
level has to make sense for the
characters like why would Tom Hardy's
venom wind up in the AMC why would he
cross over dimensions or why would Tom
Hollands spider-man cross over into the
venom verse dimension really good
example of that is why would Hulk cross
over with Thor aside from it just being
a cool idea the main reason that
happened is because Disney was never
going to be able to release a Hulk movie
because of the universal rights
situation but Kevin Feige really really
wanted to release a Hulk movie so this
was the compromise you give Hulk a movie
broken up in a couple crossovers between
three separate movies including Thor
Ragnarok Avengers infinity war in
Avengers end game hands-down best reason
for why crossover like this would happen
is so they can build up to a live-action
spider-man into the spider-verse
with Tom Horne's Peter Parker so how do
you do that you do maximum carnage for
the third venom film something happens
and because of
snaps that tore a hole in reality with
fantasy snap and Hulk snap Ironman snap
maybe you consider Santos's second snap
also really bad one two out of that
chaos one of the symbiotes or carnage
himself causes some problems that
creates the circumstances for Tom
Hollands Peter Parker to accidentally
fall into the venom burst and then find
himself dealing with venom carnage and
then eventually once they developed the
idea of the multiverse working their way
up to a live-action spider-man into the
spider verse so let me know in the
comments what do you want that venom
spider-man crossover to look like once
they get to it in a couple years and
what will happen is is we add in more
news about that I will include it in
videos but like I said non spoilery
reactions to spider-man far from home
may be posting sometime mid next week
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big video dr. Spock please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details click here for
that new funny spider-man Thor crossover
promo that Chris Hemsworth did with Tom
Holland and click here for that funny
spider-man far from home Jimmy Kimmel
scene thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you